today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video we have
some major very consequential news from
the Supreme Court major decisions that
the Supreme Court don't happen every day
we got a very very important decision
yesterday where the Supreme Court has
decided that the language of the Civil
Rights Act of 1964 protects LGBT workers
under the sex discrimination provision
now this is something I've been talking
to you about for years and in fact since
the June of 2015 Supreme Court decision
which said States can't ban same-sex
marriage we knew we predicted we've been
watching as the the sort of new focus of
anti-gay bigotry has been employment
discrimination so-called religious
freedom when it comes to LGBT workers
and even though LGBT workers even though
LGBT folks have been able to marry in
all 50 states
since June of 2015 in many states you
can still legally fire someone for their
perceived or actual sexual orientation
and perceived as an important part of
that you don't actually have to be LGBT
to be fired if someone thought you were
as crazy as that is and in many states
either way it is legal so this decision
from the Supreme Court was a six to
three decision which with Donald Trump's
appointee Neil Gorsuch writing the
majority opinion which we will address a
Gorsuch was joined by Chief Justice John
Roberts a bush appointee as well as Ruth
Bader Ginsburg a justices Breyer
Sotomayor and Kagan so all of this goes
back to title 7 of the Civil Rights Act
of 64 and that 7th title 7 very clearly
says workers can't be discriminated
against by their employers on the basis
of race religion national origin and sex
and
what was really at issue in this case is
whether sex as designated in 1964
includes sexual orientation and gender
identity
so understand that the people fighting
for LGBT discrimination here were Trump
administration lawyers the Trump
administration was the the side arguing
that back in 1964 when people talked
about sex discrimination they meant bias
against men or women quite simply that
they argued Trump's lawyers did that
this provision in 1964 does not include
sexual orientation it doesn't include
gender identity and that if you want to
protect those characteristics you would
need a new law that the sixty-four law
would not protect them now the
counter-argument which is a strong one
that ultimately was accepted by the
court and and the court sided with this
argument the other argument was any
decision made about sexual orientation
or transgender status is by definition
about sex as designated in 1964 so I'll
give you an example if you're
discriminating against someone because
they are a man attracted to other men
right which would be sexual orientation
discrimination you are singling them out
as men attracted to men rather than
women attracted to men meaning they're
male sex is part of the discrimination
period another example if you are firing
someone because they are transgender it
is because you've evaluated that their
biological birth sex differs from their
current gender identity and thus sex is
part of that discrimination so this is a
very important decision
two of the three big pillars of anti-gay
discrimination have been toppled have
been locked knocked down in the last
five years so back in 2015 Supreme Court
decided you can't stop people from being
married even if they are both men or
both women same-sex marriage bans are
banned
now in 2020 almost exactly five years
later the Supreme Court decided that
employees cannot be discriminated
against on the basis of their sexual
orientation and gender identity those
are two of the three pillars the last
pillar would be including sexual
orientation in business
non-discrimination law in the sense of
you can choose in many states to refuse
service to someone on the basis of their
sexual orientation real or perceived
there are many states that have outlawed
this but there are many states that have
not and a Supreme Court decision on that
would be sort of breaking down the third
anti-gay pillar now there are some
caveats here this is a good decision and
this is the right decision but there are
some important things to think about
first of all this decision from the
Supreme Court may well prevent some LGBT
folks from being fired but others are
still going to be fired and employers
will just be more careful about how they
do it they certainly won't say it has
anything to do with sexual orientation
or gender identity but it still could be
and there are going to be a lot of legal
cases very expensive legal cases that
will be fought over can you prove that
it was actually because of sexual
orientation or gender identity this is a
big problem in general in employment
discrimination number two many states
don't require an explanation about why
you're firing someone these are at-will
states where an employer can just say
your position has has been eliminated we
no longer require your services and that
would make it very difficult to really
know if one of these protected statuses
is at play now there are also other
legal infrastructures like for example
the Fair Housing Act which aren't
affected by this decision
so the Fair Housing Act will maybe be
fought in court and you could point to
this decision as president but right now
the Fair Housing Act doesn't ban
discrimination against for example LGBT
tenants so a landlord could say I don't
want LGBT tenants in a lot of states and
that would not be banned by the Fair
Housing Act
maybe this decision from yesterday could
be used to justify changing the Fair
Housing Act now just one other really
important thing
for context the Trump administration
just rolled back protections for trans
people two days ago so yesterday's
decision is progress it's a step forward
and on Monday we had a step back and
this is all still a really big fight and
this is just one piece of the pie one
piece of the puzzle lastly and very
importantly if we don't vote Donald
Trump out in November he gets to pick in
all likelihood more Supreme Court
justices and he will mostly choose
people who will fall on the wrong side
of causes like these now a lot of people
are gonna say but David hold on Gorsuch
who trump selected was with the majority
here that's right he happened to get it
right but let's be frank this was a
really obvious case the three justices
who dissented III vehement ly disagree
with and this was a relatively easy case
all things considered if we want to be
sure that we get more decisions like
this in the future we have to be
absolutely positive that it's going to
be Joe Biden appointing Supreme Court
justices rather than Donald Trump let's
not forget about that as we are just
four-and-a-half months from a
presidential election we've been talking
a lot about what could happen between
now in the November election that could
propel Donald Trump to re-election now
Trump is down dramatically in a number
of different polls to Joe Biden we're
going to talk about it a little later
right now Trump is losing among women
Trump is losing young voters Trump's
losing older voters minority voters
Trump's strong group is middle-aged
white men essentially but things can
change very quickly and there's a piece
in the New York Times by two doctors
from the University of Pennsylvania
including Zeke Emanuel outlining a
scenario where Donald Trump could force
some version of a corona virus vaccine
into emergency use in October and
October surprise so to speak and propel
himself to re-election I would even add
an alternative which is Donald Trump
will take what is already a likely
scenario I mean we a lot of reasonable
sober road
Maps have said for months now we are
sort of expecting it's like a 50-50
maybe even more likely shot that there's
an emergency use vaccine for healthcare
workers in the fall Trump could simply
try to take credit for it despite the
fact that he would have absolutely
nothing to do with such a vaccine
because dozens of vaccines have been
under development since before Donald
Trump was even taking coronavirus
seriously right now there are more than
120 candidate vaccines ten of which are
already in human trials we have phase
three trials starting in some of those
vaccines and from a mathematical
perspective it's likely one of these
vaccines is going to work and it will
have nothing to do with Donald Trump we
have already seen again the expectation
from some of the big financial firms
which think what you will about them
they tend to make analyses that are
based in fact many big financial firms
in thinking about the economic recovery
are expecting that by October there will
be some vaccine doses available for
healthcare workers and even if all of
that fails Donald Trump could try to
strong-arm the FDA to approve something
that's not really ready for approval
he'd need some pharma company to be
complicit but the point of the op-ed in
the New York Times is this is not
completely inconceivable and it would of
course be very dangerous if it's not
actually the right time for a vaccine to
be approved but Donald Trump thinks that
he could get an electoral victory by
announcing I got the vaccine before
everybody else
open up businesses I fixed it let's go
back to work if that happened in mid or
late October it could generate just
enough confusion and craziness that
Trump gets himself re-elected assuming
he suppresses the vote enough in
November which is another aspect of the
2020 Trump campaign limiting the number
of people who end up voting so there are
a couple things that would be important
to understand if there were an emergency
use vaccine in the fall and I hope there
is it would in all likelihood only be
available to healthcare workers and
maybe by the end of the year we would
start to see more doses for some of the
most vulnerable Americans
it would have nothing to do with Donald
Trump whatsoever but number two it is
really important to also understand that
a lot of these vaccines even predate
this coronavirus in the sense that there
are vaccines developed for poultry that
have been around for a while for a
corona virus in poultry that are being
tweaked none of this stuff would have
anything to do with Donald Trump but it
doesn't matter because it's all optics
and what can he take credit for and
what's incredible to see is since the
start of corona virus we've seen
anti-vaxxers spout conspiracies about
Bill Gates is the reason why they
wouldn't get a corona virus vaccine or
whatever there is now in light of this
op-ed there's a crowd of people now who
are Pro vaccine but who are worried if a
vaccine is pushed out in September or
October by Donald Trump's FDA if it's
approved by Trump's FDA people are now
legitimately worried would it actually
be safe because Donald Trump has started
to control all sorts of regulatory
agencies they mostly are doing his
bidding
Pro vaccine people are worried you know
if this is just a trump stunt in October
maybe it wouldn't actually be a safe
vaccine which is an incredible thing to
see and think about last point I want to
make from a perspective of practicality
Donald Trump has already proven himself
completely incompetent and unfit to lead
and what's happened up to today
justifies his immediate and speedy
removal from the office of the White
House
whatever vaccine developments happen
between now and Election Day would have
nothing to do with Trump and wouldn't
justify his re-election this is a really
important point
only people who want to get bamboozled
by Trump so they don't feel bad about
voting for him in 2016 and again in 2020
or just straight-up ignorant people are
going to fall for it
but unfortunately the 2016 election
proves that there are lots of people who
meet that criteria thus we have to get
out there and make sure we get every
single vote while we hope that a vaccine
is actually say
we made available as soon as possible
very important no nobody on the left
wants people to die nobody on the left
wants the economy to fail to hurt Trump
Trump has already justified his
immediate removal again if he cures
cancer and ends a climate change by
November come and talk to me but his
actions already justify his immediate
removal tonight join me for the David
Pakman show chess tournament number two
sign up for free at david pakman.com
slash chess already over 300 people
signed up to play hoping for a thousand
I'll see you at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
tonight don't miss it the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are Kim
Dozier and Mabel boy Jim and Mabel thank
you for your support also a big thank
you to Edith Hammond who is today's
longtime sustaining member of the day
membership is the primary funding source
of this program all of these other
funding sources that come and go and are
irregular and are subject to algorithms
and all of this the steady revenue
source which is our primary revenue
source is just people who go to join
pakman.com and sign up quick easy cheap
and it just feels good to support
alternatives to homogeneous corporate
media consider yourself invited grab a
membership donald trump recently said
that bigotry and Prejudice are going to
leave very easily and quickly from the
united states
just hours after using a racial slur
himself against a sitting democratic
senator you probably know that trump has
a long history of claiming that certain
problems are going to be really easy to
fix you might remember that he said
coronavirus was just going to leave in
april it's gonna wash through and leave
like a miracle obviously that didn't
happen he also said three and a half
years ago that his son-in-law Jared
Kushner was going to very easily and
quickly fix the israeli-palestinian
conflict obviously that has not happened
and here is Donald Trump speaking at a
so-called transition to greatness event
saying it himself bigotry will leave
quickly and easily just hours after he
tweeted the slur pocahontas about
senator Elizabeth Warren here is Donald
Trump himself saying it Americans are
good and virtuous people we have to work
together to confront bigotry and
Prejudice wherever they appear but we'll
make no progress and heal no wounds by
falsely labeling tens of millions of
decent Americans as racist or bigots we
have to get everybody together we have
to be in the same same path I think
pastor if we don't do that we
we have problems and we'll do that we'll
do it I think we're gonna do it very
easily it'll go quickly and it'll go go
very easily so so it's so part of the
solution to bigotry and racism from
Seth's is to stop calling people racist
when they say racist things and then
racism will very quickly leave our
country and remember just hours before
Trump said this he tweeted a slur about
Elizabeth Warren where he said quote
seriously failed presidential candidate
senator Elizabeth Pocahontas Warren just
introduced an amendment on the renaming
of many of our legendary military bases
from which we trained to win two world
wars
hopefully our great Republican senators
won't fall for this also relevant to
racism and bigotry is that Donald Trump
was attacking Elizabeth Warren because
she introduced an amendment looking to
rename American military bases that were
named after pro-slavery Confederate
generals remember the Confederacy was
fighting to preserve states rights for
legal slavery during the American Civil
War this is the same Donald Trump who
told four American Congress women of
color to go back to their countries this
is the same Trump who referred to
African countries as you know what
obviously Donald Trump as we know is in
way over his head and himself is a
heavily bigoted individual but I want to
put you in his shoes for a moment as
gross as that might feel if you don't
have any understanding of bigotry and
racism if you don't understand the
history of bigotry and racism in the
United States as Donald Trump doesn't
understand if you don't understand how
long bigotry and racism have been around
in the United States and how ingrained
in the country they are you might
believe that you could really quickly
and easily fix bigotry and racism in
reality what's going on is that Donald
Trump completely lacks self-awareness
and is himself a huge part of the
problem in general when Trump is wrong
about something or may
a mistake which he never admits to of
course you can usually chalk it up to a
combination of him being what we might
call a bad person like he lacks empathy
completely you can chalk it up to him
being ignorant some would call it stupid
but that's a bit of a pejorative
ignorant maybe is better and/or that
he's delusional in other words he lives
in a fantasy world that includes
delusions of grandeur etc in this case
Trump saying bigotry will leave quickly
and easily it's a lack of empathy for
the problems with bigotry in our country
combined with ignorance about the
history of bigotry and racism in the
United States with the addition of the
delusion he holds that he can fix any
problem it's sort of like the perfect
trifecta now one last thing I know that
some of you lovely right-wingers are
going to write to me or leave a comment
on youtube or tweet me and you're gonna
say David pocahontas isn't a slur with
somebody's name skip it skip I'm not
gonna respond to you I'll tell you right
now Donald Trump is using it as a slur
here - sarcastically refer to what in
her family was an oral history of Native
American ancestry this is sort of like
if you sarcastically
or pejoratively refer to a Jewish person
as slo-mo when [ __ ] is not their name
you would have these same right-wingers
going David slo-moes just short for
Solomon it's just a name how is it a
slur the context matters and the context
can make it a slur so please guys right
right wingers put in it is mostly guys
not women don't even bother writing to
me about it okay in the context Trump
used it it was a slur I want to talk
about a genius idea to end the corona
virus pandemic okay this is not a new
idea Donald Trump had this idea some
months ago but he's revitalizing it
here's the idea okay we want to get rid
of all cases ready for this stop testing
don't do a single test we won't find a
single case this is the idea that Donald
Trump again is suggesting proposing he
said this yesterday during one of those
lame propaganda roundtable events he was
asked about the reality that the United
States is still finding 20,000 or
more new coronavirus cases today states
are reopening some states very unsafely
Arizona Florida Texas North Carolina
California these states are having more
and more and more cases almost every
single day
Trump's about to hold a huge rally in
Oklahoma well what if we just stop
testing take a look you just have to see
it to believe it
as I said this morning that's probably
the downside of having good testing as
you find a lot of cases at other
countries who don't even test don't have
if you don't test you don't have any
cases if we stop testing right now would
have very few cases if any but we do
we're at a level that mike is going to
talk about that's so high but we will
show more more cases when other
countries have far more cases than we do
then just don't talk about it
so there's actually so much to discuss
here and it's it's kind of a good
opportunity to do a little bit of a
reset in terms of where we are
nationally with coronavirus right now so
first of all remember testing more we'll
find more cases that that's true
generally speaking but testing more over
the long run reduces the spread because
as more people become aware that they
have the disease they stay home if
they're normal people and they don't
give it to other people so yeah in a
sense if you don't do any tests you
don't find any cases but in terms of the
real spread the more testing you do the
better you mitigate the spread of
coronavirus by the way we're still not
testing 500,000 people a day on average
a couple times in the last 10 days we
hit this number 500,000 tests a day
we've been talking about needing to be
at a minimum of 500 thousand a day for
three months at this point we're still
not there
okay so reminder we still are not
testing enough then Trump continues to
insist that we test so much we test more
than anybody the u.s. is currently 28th
in testing globally this is per capita
testing this is a really important
detail about testing because one of the
reasons a couple months ago we were like
45th in testing now we're 28th one of
the reasons that we've inched up to 28th
and testing is
there are countries that no longer need
to test because they've eradicated the
virus imagine that like for example
South Korea we talked about South
Korea's early testing program now the
United States is testing more than South
Korea why because South Korea only ever
got to 12,000 total cases South Korea
only ever had
278 deaths total the entire pandemic in
South Korea was 278 deaths so of course
we're now testing more than South Korea
they don't really have a corona virus
pandemic secondly there are other
indicators about how the virus is going
even if you don't test so you could
suppress testing numbers like Trump is
talking about for some period of time
but you have hospitalizations you have
ICU usage and eventually cases turned to
death so even if you don't test
eventually the truth get out it's like
saying if Trump doesn't get himself
tested for an STD he won't test positive
for an STD well that's true but
eventually things are gonna start
looking a little bit wrong if you
understand what I'm saying now it's true
that it's harder to find the
hospitalization numbers most national
dashboards include cases and deaths not
hospitalization so you've got to dig a
little bit more but the data is there
one other really bizarre moment from
this roundtable Trump was asked about
hydroxychloroquine being taken off of
the FDA's emergency use list it was
taken off because it's not working and
Donald Trump very irresponsibly promoted
it for a long time
Trump said when he was asked about this
well there were good reports about
hydroxi from other countries but then he
sort of got irritated with his own
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Alex a czar and turned to Alex a czar
and said why don't we have some of these
good reports Alex take a look great
reports coming out of friends coming out
of Spain coming out of other places the
only place we don't get necessarily
reports are coming out of Alex's agency
or wherever they come from I don't
understand that Alex what is it exactly
yeah because I have heard I have had so
many people that were so thrilled with
the results from hydroxy so what is that
exactly well your direction we continue
to study especially in earlier faiths so
a lot of the data that has come out that
was more negative was people who were
quite ill in the hospital people that
were like seriously you know like they
weren't gonna make it let's give a
little hydroxy and then they don't make
and they say oh well maybe the president
was wrong all I know is that we've had
some tremendous reports I've had a lot
of people tell me that they think it
saved their lives you know the one woman
whose affair so this is just great
insight into Donald Trump's lack of
understanding of how medical research
works what randomized controlled trials
are what it means to have a placebo
group and and so on and so forth
double-blind how you actually test
something empirically and arguably even
worse is that people around Trump like
Alex a czar continued to placate Trump
and pretend like well you know yes some
of those tests were on very sick people
but we should really be looking into
hydroxychloroquine on people who aren't
so sick yet prophylactic use they just
keep play Kading trump endlessly now one
more thing to prepare you for the coming
wave of propaganda the Trump
administration is already floating blame
Mexico in terms of you know some of
these states now having spikes our
southern states that share a border with
Mexico Arizona Texas for example so
they're floating blame Mexico for the
spikes no evidence of that by the way
that Mexico is responsible
combined with blame protesters even
though a lot of the states that had the
bigger protests are places that are not
seeing a spike the protesters mostly
wearing masks whereas in places like
Arizona and Texas things are open almost
nobody's wearing masks and that's really
what we should be looking at so just to
prepare you for the coming of propaganda
wave make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show for more
on testing and cases and Trump isms that
continue to plague the country the david
pakman show at david pakman.com the
david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show it's great to
be joined today by Tara Isabella Burton
who is the author of strange rights new
religions for a godless world and the
novel social creature
tarah it's so great to have you on oh
thank you so much for having me I'm
delighted to be here so many of us and
many in my audience have seen the
studies that show that adherence to
organized religion and identification as
as religious and as members of
individual religions have declined in
the United States but there's another
sort of side to this which is the idea
of spirituality which can take a lot of
different forms and you talk about ways
in which while sort of more traditional
religiosity is being rejected that we're
not necessarily seeing a decrease in
this broader umbrella of spirituality
can you talk about how spirituality is
different than religiosity and maybe
give us some examples of where we're
seeing it sure so just for a little bit
of background like as you say about a
quarter of Americans identify as
religiously unaffiliated often they
called the N o ne nuns that number goes
up to 36% of Americans born after 1985
so we're talking about a huge proportion
of particularly millennial and younger
population the however that doesn't mean
as you say that they're not interested
in spirituality and spirituality
at least as I understand it and as I
work on it and my book is about sort of
various elements of religious life
unbundled you might say divorced from
organized religion which which is itself
about so much more than just personal
belief organized religion and indeed any
religion you might say has sort of a
component that is belief and Dogma a
search for meaning individual purpose
but also community understanding of a
kind of social place and the rituals
that kind of find that community
together and what we're seeing isn't
necessarily some that spirituality is
somehow different from organized
religion and offering those different
things but often that we find people
young Americans in particular more
willing to find these different
components of religious life from a
variety of sources
someone might for example still go to
like Christmas and Easter services or
various High Holy Days with their
families a couple times a year have a
sense of community from a hobby that
they do also practice meditation or yoga
kind of privately and really just
creating their own religion rather than
sort of adopting wholesale the model of
an existing organized tradition so
what's the difference between some of
what you describe and just a lifestyle
in the sense that I mean one could
imagine that one finds for example
veganism yoga and bicycling to be sort
of related to the values that they
exhibit and dealing with the problems
they most acutely identify as needing
solutions or whatever how do we how
would we distinguish that from whether
it is a lifestyle whether it has a sort
of spiritual istic component whether it
is more religious what are the lines or
or maybe it's a gray area so I actually
think it is a gray area I think it's
almost impossible to actually have a
working definition of religion you see
this actually in other areas where
people are often sort of talking about
cults what makes a cult versus a
quote-unquote normal religion the lines
are blurry I sometimes I joke it's
like porn you know it when you see it
but at the same time even within sort of
academic definitions of religion like
there are as many definitions of
religion as there are scholars of
religion and my book I talk about sort
of Durkheim or Clifford Geertz all of
whom see religion is completely
different it's about belief no it's
about society no it's about symbols and
sort of a shared understanding all of
these things are also true more broadly
so I think a useful way to think about
it is not kind of is this a religion is
it not a religion but looking at the
ways in which organized religions have
traditionally been kind of transmission
vectors or places for a lot of the
components of religious life all at once
you know your your sense of meaning your
sense of purpose your sense of community
and your sense of ritual largely coming
from one place this was all the more
true when for example where you were
shipped on Sunday or any other day of
the week for that matter would also be
where you met people you were most
likely to perhaps form a relationship
and marry and have children with a
community that sort of supported you
through your various life stages your
values your sense of ritual your sense
of meaning and purpose we're tied up and
I say you're a sort of traditionally in
America more broadly like sort of this
stereotype of the 1950s where what
church you get went to was a sort of by
word for a whole other host of social
associations and that's really what
we've lost and the quote-unquote
spiritual but not religious or secular
age rather than belief or interest in
the metaphysical or the divine well
thinking earlier than the 1950s in
earlier human history there was a time
which I find very interesting where but
membership in a religious group actually
conferred an evolutionary advantage in
the sense that you you were far more
likely if you got along with the people
around you than if you didn't to survive
and to have enough food to eat and to go
on to have children and and you know
procreate and pass on your genes that
element of religion has dramatically
diminished certainly we could probably
find some places in the world where it
exists but but in modern Western world
that that's not a factor I'm interested
in
whether youth you see the sort of modern
lifestyle slash spirituality vectors
having some component of that advantage
in society maybe not literally to our
survival but to some degree of
prospering maybe yes I mean yes and no
and what I mean by that is
simultaneously I think that the kind of
new tribalism that we formed through
various affiliations often by as
distinct from religions into which we
were often born are determined by choice
you know we are part of this group or
that group our interest in CrossFit you
know or or what-have-you
gives us a sort of family we choose in a
very particular way at the same time
though I think that so much of the way
in which the sort of contemporary
spirituality works is through a quite
individualized model we basically each
make our own religion in that way and I
say we soar more broadly but
particularly young Americans tend to be
more likely to mix and match even and
this isn't exclusive to people who call
themselves religious nuns there was a
2018 pew study that found that about 30
percent of self-identified Christians
also said like I believe in
reincarnation about a similar number
said they believe in psychics astrology
things are not traditionally understood
within the Orthodox Christian umbrella
we're seeing more broadly a willingness
on the part of both the religious
traditionally religious and the
unaffiliated to kind of create through
through choice through what they by the
classes they take it's often a very sort
of consumerist choice their owns or
spiritual identity especially in a
internet-based capitalist world such as
we are in that often means voting with
your dollars kind of consuming as a form
of creating you know do you buy the
Sephirah which kit which has its starter
pack of tarot cards which was for awhile
available on kind of the the high street
until it was actually withdrawn over a
bit of controversy do you spend your
money on a yoga class or meditation app
and I
think the way in which we've become sort
of more atomized more individual in part
because of this sort of obsession with
our own choices our own affinities has
made perhaps this iteration of
spirituality a little bit less group
focused I would say then religion as
traditionally understood well one of the
interesting things that you mentioned
gets into some of the examples that
relate to one of the characteristics
that's often present in certainly the
more devout areas of the traditional
religions is that there's not a very
strong sort of error-correcting
mechanism the way science has we're
questioning the beliefs and changing the
beliefs is is welcomed a lot of times
the community leader and more
established religious religions doesn't
welcome people coming in and saying I
think that you're actually wrong about
this that the other thing and saying hey
we made a mistake let's change what the
what the Scriptures are that's often not
encouraged and sorry when I look at some
of the modern ways in which we might
explore spirituality or religion I I
sort of pay attention to that and so for
example I had an experience with the
followers of this gentleman named Jordan
Peterson a couple of years ago where
there were a lot of examples of when I
would critique something he said or did
there was a sort of post hoc
rationalization of your misunderstand
you you have to be misunderstanding what
he said and therefore your critique is
not accurate or another example might be
either you know Flat Earth or astrology
where you might try to say hey let's try
to apply some critical thinking and the
idea of revising the dogma as it maybe
is not at all welcomed is that the case
in a lot of these spirituality outlets
that you look at not in a lot how
present is that it's present but I'd say
in a slightly different form which is to
say often these groups or rather that
these practices as instantiated in
individuals have come up in part because
they're sort of we have such a profound
public distrust now in Institute
there is a sort of you know particularly
religious institutions from sex abuse
scandals to the political alliance of
particularly white of angelical
Christianity with the GOP to say nothing
of sort of the broader failures of
institutions we see whether it's sort of
the dissents of the media or politics or
what-have-you there is I would argue a
widespread sense that because
institutions have failed we can no
longer trust them what do you do when
you can't trust an institution when you
can't trust science or you think you
can't trust science or journalists or
the establishment you turn it inwards
there's a sense in which it is sort of
similarly perhaps it is I don't want to
say anti intellectual perhaps that's too
strong but intuitional there are a lot
of these movements from wellness culture
to to an extent even some of the
followers of jordan Peterson in a
certain way although he is a sort of
leader which adds a different dimension
but the idea that you focus you turn
inward you focus on yourself which is
what you can control and what you can
rely on and I think that that you often
find that in a lot of the conspiracy
theorists and even the way that a lot of
like jordan peterson fans will sort of
talk about him versus the sort of the pc
establishment that's hiding truths from
you there is a very much an
anti-establishment anti institutional
strain to a lot of these beliefs and so
i think on the one hand there's a
rejection of kind of dogma in the
abstract as something that institutions
do that we don't want to sort of succumb
to and yet there is also a resistance to
for example in the case of like wellness
culture you know not have very few of
the scientific facts on quite at the
Paltrow's website GUP are we might say
they are not always fact checked to the
fullest extent and indeed they I think
gotten quite a bit of trouble over that
but I think the narrative goes something
like well like this feels true and it's
completely understandable that when a
person might think that none of the
authorities around them are worth
listening to they can't rely on them
suddenly you know like going with your
gut there are worse things you can do I
I'm interested in talking a little bit
about the protest we've seen over the
last couple of weeks protests
I widely support the the objectives of
and and which I'm sympathetic to I've
seen some examples I don't have you know
feel the need to say this is a lot or
not a lot but I've seen examples of
would seem almost like pseudo religious
types of moments where black people in
large groups are I'm sorry white people
in large groups apologize to black
people for their privilege or calls for
white people to give the black people at
the protest money in some kind of
symbolic reparations that things that
things that to me start to feel a little
bit cult-like and that they go beyond
sort of the activism component to it how
should we be applying this religiosity
spirituality analysis to the movement
we're seeing take hold over the last
couple of weeks sure I think speaking
more broadly about the social justice
we've been as I do in the book I mean I
think it's absolutely right to apply
this scholar of religions lens or the
religious lens to it and I think that
when people often do that sort of it's
often a charge that is leveled against
the social justice movement from right
you know there's elet's there a religion
they're a cult etc I'd like to sort of
say that you know something of a bit
more complicated which is that yes it is
religious in nature that is both as with
any any movement the good and the bad of
it which is to say I think the the sense
of hope a sense of profundity the sense
that this is meaningful that there is a
a better world at the end of all this
which is you know quite striking I think
in our some somewhat alienated
capitalist world one might say there
aren't that many places for not just the
sacred or or or enchantment but a vision
of that enchantment that is linked up
with a vision of the world how its it
should be things like wellness culture
are very individualistic as I've said
you know you great you can you can
achieve a sort of in light a minute soul
cycle but it begins and ends with you
and I think that it's absolutely right
to talk about the kind of symbolism the
sense of catharsis the collective
effervescence as Durkheim might say
that you might find in a protest
movement as being in religious and
nature but I think that's why it's
that's what I would say that's why it's
been so successful so widespread
precisely because it is able to harness
a kind of religious longing this is not
just a group of people protesting it is
people sort of getting in touch with a
perhaps not a divine purpose but a sort
of fundamentally real purpose to change
the world to make it better or certainly
a purpose that's bigger than them yes
absolutely absolutely and I think it
brings it both brings people together
which especially after however many
months of isolation I think is all the
more appealing and it provides a
framework to kind of see in a world that
could very well see meaningless and
chaotic some form not just a meaning in
the abstract but but purpose what one
person's individual life individual
choices to to protest to to get involved
how that might link up with a kind of
grander cosmic bigger than them scale so
I think that it's absolutely right to
think about it in terms of religion but
also sort of the question to ask us not
like are they a religion and therefore
should it be sort of discounted as
irrational but rather as a religion what
is this offering that other forms of
living in 2020 aren't necessarily
offering know how what why is this so
meaningful and compelling very very
interesting we've been speaking with
Tara
Isabella Burton who's author of strange
rites new religions for a godless world
and also author of the novel social
creature Tara so great having you on I
really appreciate it thank you so much
it was lovely the david pakman show at
david pakman
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
all right my friends let's look at some
stunning polling numbers Donald Trump's
favorite pollster Rasmussen is a
right-wing friendly pollster has a new
poll out where Donald Trump is down by
12 points to Joseph R Biden Jr when
other polls don't look good for Trump
Trump often says look at Rasmussen
Rasmussen does good polling well here is
Rasmussen latest poll with RMG research
saying Trump is down 12 to Biden 48 to
36 with 9% not sure and 6% supporting
some other candidate now important to
understand that there are 15% here that
are either for some third party
candidate or aren't sure yet
if they mostly consolidate around Trump
in November that can get Trump close
enough where even he could lose the
popular vote by a few points but still
win the electoral college we saw that in
2016 but the reason that this poll
matters is that last week when CNN said
hey we have a poll done with SSRS
reliable reputable pollster says Trump
is down 14 Trump said it was fake had
his lawyers send a cease and desist
letter to CNN demanded an apology and
demanded a retraction
we now have a traditionally right-wing
pollster saying well it's not a 14-point
lead for Biden but it's a 12-point lead
for Biden and in addition we have an
abacus data or data poll from yesterday
which also has this as a 14-point lead
for Joe Biden so what is our take away
the take away is nothing every single
one of you of us me you have everybody
every one of us has to vote no matter
what any poll says because Donald Trump
is desperate and he will do anything he
can to get reelected they are going to
try to suppress the vote they are going
to try to come up with some October
Surprise we talked earlier in the show
about maybe some emergency use vaccine
we can assume nothing if in your state
Biden is polling ahead by 30 points what
do you do you go and vote because we
can't take a chance now let's look at
some stunning state polls in the
meantime and admittedly left lean
PPP poll has Biden plus 14 in New Mexico
an epic MRA poll has Biden plus 16 in
Michigan now remember none of this
changes anything about what we have to
do but understand how 2016 went and then
if you look at 2016 where Donald Trump
won Michigan by 0.2 percent 0.2 percent
if Trump goes from winning Michigan by
0.2 percent to losing it by 16 or even
12 or even 8 or even 5 that signals a
massive change from the 2016 election
because it probably means a bunch of
states aren't going to go Donald Trump's
way another important state to look at
is Iowa Donald Trump won Iowa by 10 in
2016 the latest poll from the Des Moines
Register good pollster has Trump up only
one Trump won by 10 in Iowa in 2016
currently Trump is winning by 1 in Iowa
we have 50 individual elections when we
do a presidential election it is a
national choice
but they are 50 individual elections
they're correlated though if Trump's
margin of victory in Iowa goes from 10
to 1 it's a signal about other states
but again third time I'm saying this and
you're gonna hear this from me a lot our
mission our assignment individually is
we vote no matter what state were in we
vote no matter what the polls say if in
mid-october the stock market spikes and
Trump claims he got us a vaccine it
could push him to victory and then we
have four more years of Trump from
selecting Supreme Court justices Trump
putting in more federal and appeals
court judges so we need to be prepared
for something in October we need to be
ready to deal with it meaning every
single person must plan to vote now I
want to focus in a little more
specifically on Arkansas so listen I
don't pretend to know what's going to
happen in November with the presidential
election Donald Trump may well get
himself reelected
we did a story today about how Trump
might try to use a vaccine October
Surprise to get himself reelected
anything could happen and all of the
polling could reverse by November but we
continue to see polling signals that
four and a half months out from the
election we can't ignore them and many
of them are state polls the national
polls are interesting to look at and we
looked at that earlier when we look at a
place like Arkansas the latest poll out
of very red Arkansas is stunning Donald
Trump is leading Joe Biden in Arkansas
by only 247 to 45 now understand that in
2016
Donald Trump won Arkansas by 27 Trump
won by 27 in 2016 in 2012 Mitt Romney
beat Barack Obama in Arkansas by 24 in
2008 John McCain defeated Barack Obama
by 20 in Arkansas even if the five
percent who are currently supporting a
third-party candidate and the three
percent who were currently unsure all go
to trump between now and November in
Arkansas Trump would win Arkansas by
only 10 this would be the smallest
margin of victory for a Republican in
Arkansas I don't even know for how long
and it would signal some insane
possibilities for November also
important in looking at the internals of
this Arkansas poll are that more people
disapprove of Trump than the number that
approve this is a very red state so to
see the approval numbers turn against
Trump in Arkansas is not a good sign for
him Senator Tom cotton a Republican
whack-job from Arkansas also is
underwater he has disapproval of 47
approval of 44 so he's minus 3 there and
where this is coming from is
independence in Arkansas Arkansas has
more Republicans than Democrats as you
probably imagine the Democrats are
mostly not voting for Trump the
Republicans mostly are voting for Trump
right now independence in Arkansas are
leaning towards Joe Biden by 6 points
and so that may well be the group so to
speak that is going to
Trump some trouble now do I think
Trump's going to lose Arkansas no I
don't think he's going to lose Arkansas
is it likely that if the numbers stay
this tight Trump will have to spend some
money in Arkansas yeah it does become
likely and that's already a victory
because any dollar Trump has to spend in
Arkansas is a dollar he may not be
spending somewhere else and if it is
even remotely this close it is going to
be a real problem or Donald Trump and
this is why remember every single one of
us has to operate as if Trump could win
any state Trump seemingly could lose
some traditionally Republican states but
we also have to understand that we all
must vote every single one of us he
won't be competitive in California he
won't be competitive in Massachusetts
but why take a chance
why take a chance when the risk is four
more years four more years of Trump four
more years of environmental destruction
four more years of being the
laughingstock of the world four more
years of Supreme Court choices and all
of the things that we have been warning
about so very bad numbers for Trump they
won't change my behavior when it comes
to voting and they shouldn't change
yours either we have a voicemail line
that number is two one nine two David P
I'm gonna admit it up front this is a
very ugly voicemail about George Floyd
or George florid as this caller says
just so we get out of our echo chamber
this is an example of the perspective
that some Americans have about George
Floyd take a look yes I just don't think
that the public needs to be advised that
George florid has a long criminal record
he also had drugs in his system so you
know what is the big deal here thank you
for your time what difference does it
make whether or not George Floyd had
drugs in his system we have the
confrontation on video we know what
happened we know about eight minutes and
46 seconds of kneeling on George Floyd's
neck being on drugs doesn't mean if
police kill you it's justified being on
drugs doesn't mean
it's just a fighter that you deserve to
be shot or or in any other way hurt by
police this is very dangerous as
thinking and unfortunately it is not as
rare as people like me who live in a
blue state might think this stuff is
dangerously common this stuff explains
how Trump still has you know 39%
approval right so let's not forget that
and let's make sure that we take care of
business in November because these folks
vote very very ugly ugly voicemail oh we
have a great bonus show coming up for
you today and I also want to remind you
tonight we are playing chess it is the
second ever David Pakman show chess
tournament 8:00 p.m. Eastern today
Tuesday June 16th I hope you'll join me
register for free at david pakman.com
slash chess we'll see you tonight or on
the bonus show or tomorrow I guess
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to comm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video